before we dig into the review let's get
this sugar out on the table first Thank
You Johnny Depp for taking on this role
in being in this movie because for years
Johnny Depp's ultimately become kind of
a Tim burton-esque parody of himself for
a long time I have really been wanting
to see him take on a role where he could
really flex his acting muscles to the
new Duke could do it he did it in this
movie Thank You Johnny Debbie's never
gonna see this Johnny Depp will never
see this I just want to say that in the
beginning now let's review the movie
black mass - black mass is a true story
of Jimmy whitey bulger
and ultimately his rise to being one of
Boston's kingpins from his humble
beginnings of just being one of Boston's
[ __ ] so Johnny Depp plays this guy
let's get right into this Johnny Depp
this [ __ ] was transformation is one of
those roles an actor takes on you're
like you're not even there reminded me
of Charlize Theron and monster where
you're like you're disturbing you're
kind of gross and I don't want you near
my house near what my wife my kids my
girlfriend my dog my mother I just don't
want you near me this guy with his Dead
Eye grand in his sick little laugh
Johnny Depp kills it in this movie he
carries most of this entire thing
another great performance is joel
edgerton in this movie joel edgerton
works for the FBI he grew up with whitey
Bulger's they kind of form an alliance
was like hey I'll cover your ass you
cover my ass maybe we can rise the ranks
in our own little worlds together it is
some corrupt as [ __ ] going on murder
mayhem it spends like ten years in this
movie the bummer is everyone in this
movie is an [ __ ] there's no real good
guy leading the charge no there's no
protagonist to take out the antagonist I
really think this movie could have
benefited from that but it's not in the
movie because the main FBI agent linked
to the case is the one covering his ass
so you see some disturbing [ __ ] go down
but at a point it becomes like Game of
Thrones where you don't even get shocked
anymore you're like yeah someone else
died I know this movie had the guy you
know like Carl Hanratty chasing down
Leonardo DiCaprio and catch me if you
can Al Pacino going after Robert De Niro
and heat it would have really added a
lot of tension to it there is a guy who
comes into the movie who looks like he's
going to be that guy but really he comes
in near the end of the movie he doesn't
really do much and then the movie is
over and you're like well that could
have been awesome if you had that other
FBI guy really take the reins and lead
the charge like the movie implies that
he does but you never really see it the
first half of this movie would have felt
like Joel Edgerton and Johnny Depp's
playground then this guy comes in and he
is here to just bring it all down but
you don't really get that I feel like
that's a wasted opportunity see I'm
gonna say something really shocking here
because I know I'm known for being the
guy who's like oh the movie was about a
half an hour too long and could have cut
30 minutes out of that movie would have
been perfect I usually talk about how
movies are too long it could be shorter
this movie is a two hour movie that
feels like it was going to be a three
hour movie the movie really could have
benefited from being three hours long
that way we could have seen some
emotional gravity to the situations we
could have taken our time in this movie
the 10-year span wouldn't have felt so
condensed you give it time to breathe
see this movie as much as it's a mob
movie doesn't feel like it's a mob epic
like The Departed Goodfellas Godfather
in the end black mass is an interesting
true story because you're watching it
you're like I can't believe this [ __ ]
happen you can't make this stuff up
Johnny Depp kills it in this movie he's
great the supporting cast in this movies
are really good too I've walked out of
this movie Claude I watched it but I
think about it I'm like am I going to
own this movie in reality I'm probably
not going to I just don't feel the need
to pop in black mass on blu-ray and
watch it again
well the black mass has a solid Johnny
Depp performance the best I've seen from
him in years and I'll certainly say
black mass is worth
watching and is a good time no alcohol
required alright guys so black mass have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite Johnny Depp movie
of all time whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more